[Music]
let's finish out nostalgia ween with
another bad seat you all know the film
The Exorcist creepy girl gets possessed
and two precepts to exorcise her through
prayer and feeding shit out well four
years later John Boorman took the
directing chair to bring us the sequel
Exorcist to The Heretic and just like
the first film where people had to be
rushed to the hospital because of
scariness the people had to be rushed to
the coffee shop to wake the fuck up
[Music]
this is certainly one of the strangest
sequels to ever be constructed it has a
lot of scary ideas but no real scary
scenes its concepts are fascinating but
it's delivery it's downright silly it
has the original star but it's directed
by the same guy who push on Connery in
orange later OHS you can see where
problems might arise so let's see if the
power of Christ can compel this film
this is Exorcist 2 so it opens with
Richard Burton playing a priest who's
been called out to exorcise a girl they
say might be possessed the fine thing is
this is just how they get sarah
silverman to go to church but she breaks
loose and decides to turn up the heat
[Music]
she takes on the form of Jim Carrey and
then we cut to her stunt dummy being
burned alive we then cut to Reagan the
possess car over in the first film in
the Stanley Kubrick's day care center
where she undergoes counseling sessions
from Nurse Ratched those bad dreams are
still inside you there's nothing wrong
with me
lots of girls walk backwards down the
stairs on all fours we've been cut to
Richard Burton who discusses the
uneasiness of examining the death of
father Merrin four years after his death
but better late than sane son and their
close to the pontiff go so far as to
suggest that he was a Satanist at the
end I mean perhaps father Merrin led us
astray perhaps he took a path that no
one could follow Christ it's hard to
follow - we were young today wherever I
look I see only evil God has fallen
silent well yeah that's what most
Catholics think but you're not supposed
to say it you will conduct the
investigation so he begins his
investigation with Regan as he has
questions about her - Nurse Ratched I
can't let you question her you have a
heavy responsibility the care of her
soul the care of her mind and her body
is my responsibility father realize what
you're up against don't you what am i up
against father evil evil is a spiritual
being alive living well I'm sure a woman
who plainly showed that she's a person
of science and fact would love to go up
against me
the shock of recall could result in self
punishment but she does allow him to
watch a new psychological experiment
tested on it listen to this the device
or seizure machine as I like to call it
puts both the subject and the doctor
into a deep hypnotic state this somehow
allows the doctor to go inside her mind
and see what she's seeing okay maybe in
a sci-fi film this would be interesting
you know sir this new technology that
doesn't exist but in a horror film
especially one that was so grounded in
reality as Exorcist this seems really
out of
please do you think the first film would
work better with sci-fi technology well
set phasers to crispy III so Regan
allows Nurse Ratched into her mind but
it seems like what she's seeing is too
frightening for her heart to take so
Regan breaks the connection which should
probably snap the other woman out of it
but whatever I didn't make it so the
priest goes in to try and save her
I know wishes help me find them yeah the
priest who has never seen this thing
before and has no idea how it works why
doesn't the assistant go in or somebody
else and those what they're doing but
it's surprisingly absent I'm so glad her
mental health is so important to you
lady that must be why nobody else in the
building knows what to do if something
goes wrong protection top priority
relax tingly yes just relax or she'll
die
so Burton sees the image of the exorcism
going on while Reagan's doing the mind
meld with her goodies this was before
the jails ploy tation films right but
the priest does manage to save her and
get her back to normal
however another problem occurs when
Burton sees the drawing that Regan just
did we've got to put the fire out take
it easy it's probably some post fleshing
it's an after effect of a hypnosis
no no no no no you gotta help me we may
be too late we may be too late
quite nice shifty I acting there Bernie
what was Borman holding a laser pen to
direct you no no no no no you could help
me we may be too late we may be too late
so of course he has to search the entire
building for it or just check the floor
he's conveniently on
huh the devil must have changed the
direction of the smoke the Burton does
pretty much every wrong thing you can do
with a fire they can make an effect beat
it into submission and thereby spreading
it even further than it already was
[Music]
you know it should be amazed that
Reagan's picture matches reality but I'm
just shocked that he spread the fire so
far that it actually reached several
feet behind him good god someone take
away is junior firemen badge what you're
doing is incredibly reckless machine is
simply a device to penetrate
pathological no your Pokemon therapy
talking about therapy you don't realize
the enormous importance of your work as
much as I enjoy a little recognition
you're really absolutely yeah it's like
reading a person's mind is some sort of
big - you're so Rican starts having
dreams about a little boy in Africa
who's fighting off locusts while
something possesses her to climb out on
the edge
[Music]
Oh fun fact here this is not an effect
apparently John Boorman actually point
Linda Blair on the ledge with no means
of catching her would you like to be the
guy she landed on that she falls all
right isn't that one - Blair no I think
that's Tatum O'Neal
look closer the Reagan's caretaker comes
in to make sure she's all right
oh good morning Sharon that woman by the
way is one of the assistants from the
first movie
who will service Reagan's not mother for
the rest of the film she does permit her
to play mental flashlight tag again bow
because lord knows it works so damn well
the first time Reagan do you remember
dreaming of Father Mary yes can you see
him now yes oh by the way did I mention
that these things are ungodly slow and
boring but don't worry though we still
have three more like em to sit through
Reagan boy epic odds Africa isn't as
glamorous as I thought it would be
I have maggots in my screwed
we seen the boy Regan dreamt about
before was actually a healer and that
the demon tried to possess him in order
to destroy such goodness okay you sound
more like earth a kid from the Emperor's
New Groove but whatever I'll still try
to be scared of you Pazuzu man this
brings us to one of the biggest problems
of the film the name Pazuzu is not scary
it sounds silly very very silly and yet
they constantly repeat his name over and
over again
Pazuzu
doesn't it sort of suck out the fear
when you're building his name something
so goofy quickly pop we must get the
holy water and destroy squishy puppy
whoa squishing oh that sounds adorable
no he's not he's a horrible demon that
eats children's brains look yeah but
when you put the name squishy puppy
under him he seemed so much cuter no key
doesn't seize up oh you're right look at
that we should adopt one of those
here is not a very good karaoke singer
but he is good at possessing little boys
and knocking extra-soft a mountain so it
seems at the top of the mountain is a
holy church I wanna switch locations
there guys where father Merrin jump cuts
the boy to health but Marin saved him
never I could claim her cool more even
now I'll show you power he's still alive
where is he you want me to take you to
him yes let me teach good that it shall
be any more silly that could be the new
logo for the MGM lion
so Burton realizes he has to prepare to
travel to Africa to find the exercise
boy who grew up into the man names Akuma
which gives Regan much more time to
interact with the kids at the center put
you're talking now yes you are I can
hear you what's the matter with you
possessed by a demon what oh it's okay
he's gone oh that's okay then no one at
weeping would go go back to my first
reaction what God who wrote that line it
was why would you admit that so casually
to a stranger
a little kid no less she'd be scared
shitless so what's wrong with you Spidey
oh it's okay he's gone so it turns out
Regan brought the child speech back with
her
sporadic psychic powers that she
suddenly possesses which doesn't make
Nurse Ratched the least bit happy do you
think I could start helping some of your
other kids you know Regan it's really
very dangerous to fool around with other
people's heads please don't try anything
like that again yes just disregard the
magical telepathic child and the
incredible machine that can read minds
oh god this woman could downplay it he
likes you I would if she could but
Reagan wants to find out more about her
abilities and talks with Burton in a
museum two priests believe in ESP some
do in fact a French priest tried to shut
down thought that we'd all come together
eventually in some sort of mental
telepathy
that's fascinating the kind of world
mind in which everybody would share
interesting father Marion himself
believed that with modern scientific
research it could happen quite soon
intriguing theory but if it happens
before we're ready uh-huh
we may find ourselves pointing in the
wrong direction
uh-huh towards Satan what the fuck for
God's sakes you don't have to work
everything back to the devil just on a
theory be a theory two plus two equals
four which could possibly be Satan
so Burton finally travels to Africa
comes across that ridiculously
hard-to-reach church race to South Park
Jesus any the Mancha's to point them to
the lost body of where that one servant
fell years ago how did you know the
booty was here funny well it's pretty
close to civilization there and yet
nobody ever looked behind that one rock
did they never smell him at all did they
think it was just bad African cooking
I'm how dare you solve one of her great
mysteries American Satan so he calls on
the help of a 2-minute met baby cameo to
fly him around to see if he can find
cocoon whoa what a beautiful sunset and
that it's literally a Sun on a set I
don't know what they're fooling with
that
so Britain communicates with Reagan
again with those handy out-of-nowhere
psychic powers and she leads into cuckoo
Mo's location which coincidentally is
only three steps away from it boy
when it comes to files or African boys
that were possessed by the devil
he always seems to be in the right
location I call upon you in the name of
Father Lancaster men so we see kokumo
played by James Earl Jones with a locust
Muppet on his head as he tells Burton
that if he wants to speak to him he must
test his faith so he spits a tomato onto
the spikes makes sense to me I don't
know what your problem is and Britain
tries to make it across can I help you I
feel my name is kokumo did you ever know
her father Lancaster Merrin
let me guess we're just totally going to
ignore the fact that he fell on top of a
bunch of spikes and James Earl Jones was
dressed like the kindergarten production
of district 9 yes that's what I thought
you know this film raises so many
questions that nobody drunk or sober
would ever want to answer the brushing
of the Wiis changes their personality
they become a destructive for asia's
marauding swamp so he traveled all this
way just to discover what he could in a
National Geographic as Regan decides to
run away and try to find him in order to
continue their psychic link and when she
know it they happen to meet up
others like him began to appear in the
world Satan has sent to Azusa to destroy
this country Philip you must take my
place she's precious and I trust her the
spirit of Maron is in Regan I think but
they need to stop Pazuzu who was also in
Regan I think you know I'm sorry didn't
we spend a whole goddamn movie trying to
get this spirit out of her how the hell
did she end up with two fucking spirits
that's the exact opposite of why you
were supposed to go instead of taking
one now you put another one in I think
you deserve your money from the
collection plate back Soperton feels all
the answers are at the original house
where the first exorcism took place
ratchet on the caretaker find out about
this and get a cab to drive them there
as well there Burton discovers that the
room is
you know if you like locusts and really
slow blinking lights this movie is
probably a god-sent to you
[Music]
oh yeah
I'm sure after a car gets totaled by
smashing into a brick wall and a metal
gate I walk out with just a scratch on
my head - I've got to get inside let me
inside
[Music]
in answer to a question I have no idea
why she didn't maybe the idea is she's
being possessed too or maybe she just
cracked at some point I don't know what
I do know it's what's going on inside oh
wait no I don't he's chosen me Pazuzu
Reagan is the only Reagan so I guess
there's somehow to physical Reagan's now
the Pazuzu one who's looking an awful
lot like Dwight from the office and the
good one who for some reason is having a
hard time stopping Burton from acting
like a perverted pedophile positions
more weird than he is scary
[Music]
yes as to what's coming up next
either I swear to god here more locusts
or more blinking lights well see how we
just encountered the locust a few
seconds ago I think this calls for even
more goddamn locusts you know maybe this
climax would be more fitting if you were
fighting dozer but for an exorcist movie
this is pretty overdone
so Burton literally punches his way to
her heart
it's her column our fatality joke here
well the good Regan tries to figure out
how to stop the locusts
[Music]
that's right it's I'm not gonna lie I
have no idea what this it's somehow
she's defeating the locust like the
little boy with the slingshot despite
the fact that she has no slingshot yet
she can dissolve them the way I hear the
credits on the way so I'm just gonna
skip over this anyway of the human race
subdued until Isis is three which will
somehow involve George Z's got I
understand the world so Lee now do the
people come out to look at the damage
I guess the car crash constant screaming
and house demolished by locusts didn't
wake them up heavy sleepers as Burton
and Regan walk into the sunset to live
from a world that will never understand
them much like how people walked away
from this movie because we will never
understand it well it has some neat
ideas the execution of this film is
really goofy for an exorcist sequel it's
pretty piss-poor especially when you
take into account it's never scary oh I
don't mean like they try to scare you
and it fails I mean literally they never
even made an effort there's no jump
scares or scary imagery or anything like
that it's really weird that way
well it's nowhere close to one of the
worst sequels I've ever seen it's still
pretty bad and should only be brought
out if you have a locust fetish or enjoy
torturing your ass hey I know that point
zero zero zero one percent is out there
somewhere and I think you directed this
fucker
now the nostalgia critic and I want to
be sure I never go through a nostalgia
wean again and I'm willing to go through
any ridiculous lengths to make that
happen
[Music]
my god I think it worked I think I never
have to do nostalgia ween again huh oh
my god this is incredible oh oh thank
you great spirits is there anything I
can do to repay you
Oh
[Music]
I was possessed fighting
you